deux questions étaient à l'ordre du jour
de cette session d'une part l'analyse
des résultats des élections
présidentielles et à partir de là les
tâches pour le parti dans la période à
venir et en second lieu les
enseignements de la conférence
internationale des partis communistes et
uri l'analyse des résultats de
l'élection présidentielle conduisent
donc le parti communiste à définir des
tâches pour l'avenir quelles sont elles
eh bien disons que et le discours que
vient de prononcer chaban delmas à
l'assemblée nationale confirment ces
élections n'ont résolu aucun problème
puisque en définitive le gouvernement de
chaban delmas va poursuivre sur le fond
la même politique que ses prédécesseurs
c'est à dire une politique contraire aux
intérêts des travailleurs et des masses
populaires
partant de là pour notre parti la
première question qui se trouve posée
c'est naturellement d'assurer la défense
des intérêts des travailleurs et de
toutes les couches sociales qui sont
victimes de cette politique
en second lieu le comité central a
considéré qu'il devait renforcer n'est
ce pas son travail politique & you
logique parmi la classe ouvrière et
parmi les masses populaires afin de les
rallier aux solutions que nous
préconisons pour un changement de régime
et de politiques solutions qui sont
contenus dans le manifeste que notre
parti avait adopté à champigny et qui
conserve toute sa valeur et enfin en
troisième lieu nous avons décidé
d'entreprendre une vaste campagne pour
le renforcement de l'organisation du
parti c'est-à-dire pour permettre à tous
les travailleurs manuels et
intellectuels et notamment aux jeunes
qui approuvent notre programme notre
politique d'union et qui sont prêts à
prendre place dans notre parti pour leur
permettre de devenir effectivement des
communes et les conclusions du comité
central sur la conférence de moscou
alors là je serai plus brèche
le comité central a entièrement approuvé
l'activité de sa délégation qui est des
conduits je rappelle par le camarade
waldeck rochet et il considère que les
documents qui ont été adoptées à moscou
sont d'une grande importance non
seulement pour le mouvement communiste
et ouvrier international
mais pour les peuples du monde